all right and we
are live the last word would long
cognito anybody's
fresh on that friday morning just a
little late
not that not that late but we got a
special guest to the villain but first
e how are we doing sir uh busy
this morning here's the reason why we're
a little bit uh
no helping cover stuff at work so i
literally had to like sprint home
uh to make sure we got this thing
rolling so sorry about the late start
for chat if you guys are listening to
this later you have no idea what i'm
talking about
but that being said and out of the way
uh we got an awesome guest we got some
fun stuff to chat about this morning so
that being cleared up a little late but
all's well
moving i'm fueled by focus over here so
let's let's get it rolling um who we got
joining us today
let's do this you know let's let's bring
this person in
welcome to the last word episode number
152
it's another glorious friday we're back
in front of the campfire for some more
lunar shooter discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest so we're gonna get
right into it i want to introduce a lady
whose passion for the destiny franchise
was not only a case of gaming love at
first sight but has also been a stellar
representative for community inclusion
great sherpa help and tremendous empathy
for mental health
introducing the created host of the
civil spirit youtube and twitch channels
the proud huntress yet low-key warlock
maine
who always who always makes new friends
but keeps the old because one is silver
yet the other is gold live
from new england by way of my new york
and making her debut at the campfire of
the last
word my girl lady
silversmith how you doing sis i'm pretty
good
you are ready for that amazing intro
my god absolute pleasure we got to bring
you into the campfire right
it's already right we doing what's going
on dude how you doing
i'm doing good i'm doing good feeling
good it's friday morning usually that
means
you know the end of my weekend start of
everybody else's weekend but i'm feeling
good
no doubt no doubt let's get this thing
going yeah i know you got questions i
got questions
great guests let's get to it yeah
um honestly one of the first ones
because i know if they've caught you on
a podcast before they may know this but
not everybody's gonna know and not
everybody would expect this but
normally we're gonna go into things like
gaming history what you've played before
and things like that and yours is
definitely
a very probably the most different start
to gaming that i've ever heard so tell
us basically
where you started in gaming and kind of
how it's been going since
um yeah this is an interesting one um
so basically um my former
roommate uh he showed me destiny through
just his twitch stream because he'll
stream occasionally um nothing serious
but he just showed me destiny
and i felt really you know interested by
what i saw
and at the time i didn't have a console
i didn't have you know pc
i didn't know anything about that world
quote unquote as we would say
and destiny was on the list of games
that he was like yo get this get this
get this
but as soon as i hopped into destiny uh
i did not stop i mean he stopped
playing the game and i absolutely did
not because
from the beginning this game was just so
much more than a game
it was like just a life-changing
experience for me
um yeah i come from a background where
my parents my parents don't
they don't support gaming that's just
not what they consider to be
like the ideal you know you grow up and
you you know you hold a certain kind of
profession
and yeah i ended up not falling into
that
cookie cutter um i
ultimately i don't think they would even
support the idea of me streaming i don't
think they understand it
but um ever since i played destiny i
just i
i just haven't looked back um i don't
know what the future looks like
you know now for me you know
post-destiny world but
um yeah sometimes i don't understand
when people are talking about you know
their former game experiences halo is
something i 100
don't understand i didn't play it yeah i
didn't play it
makes sense so i feel a little spoiled
because destiny is just so like
do you it's just so unique you know i
think we all know that
so i was gonna add on one other piece of
that before i send it back to you cog
um for having not played much gaming
games for most of your life are there
any ones you've heard about
been told about is do you have a list
anywhere of stuff that
destiny has unique space for you but is
there anything like
when you go to venture out or if you're
gonna take a break from destiny if that
ever happens i don't know
or is there anything on a list that's
waiting for you to play as
you know your next game or a big look
forward to or somebody else is like
okay so if you like destiny you have to
play fill in the blank is there anything
that's on a list for you that you're
waiting to get into
i'm not gonna lie i'm extremely picky i
am really spoiled with destiny
um but i did like uh the division
it's just very hard to get away from
destiny because
you know for a while it was the fear of
missing out and i was just very
dedicated to the grind like there's a
lot of things that i have that people go
like oh how do you get that i'm like you
can't get that anymore like
this don't feel good to say that don't
feel good number
one thing is trials of trials of the
nine flawless ornaments that
everybody hates me for and i'm just like
i didn't quit destiny during that time i
just didn't
yeah so i have them and everybody's
everybody's jealous
that is i think that's what so jesus it
gets not sog
yeah oh no no no yeah go ahead no
because they first saw a shout out to
slovo he he's a big destiny i mean uh
division fan so here's the video he
perks up it's kind of funny to see it's
like i'm saying what is that who said
the world yes yes yes
it's funny it's funny because when the
the division like the first one came out
everybody like quit destiny including my
roommate to jump into the division and i
i tried i tried but i was like the only
one playing destiny consistently while
nobody was around it was they was bad at
me i was like you bunch of traitors
i was i was in my feelings for a little
bit it was the first time i seen
like to your point like to your point it
was the first time
dusty really had adversity d1 and it was
during like a content drought
right and the division just comes right
into that space
and we're like yo what's going on and i
was still like
but i still love playing it and i'm
having fun like i was still playing the
destiny but yeah it was a big split for
a while
i do remember that yeah yeah and but i
remember that um
the game just ended up not being as
great as it could be i know they
they made it better down the road but
everybody had like moved on
that was gonna play the game everybody
had moved on i didn't i never i never
quit destiny
um i have never quit destiny curse of
osiris never quit it yeah
warming didn't quit it like i just never
i never quit it
um there were brief periods where i was
working two jobs and
i could only play so much but i didn't
quit yeah i was just far behind that's
life
that's different that's life you didn't
have one of those social moments like
i'm quitting destiny
never yeah i never no dramatic mic drop
moments for you just the
just the average life got busy didn't
you uh didn't you say you were quitting
last week what are you doing here like
checking out the twab
oh so you call them out when they come
back
i'm petty like i keep my mouth shut i
just go see i knew you weren't gonna
quit i knew you couldn't quit
that's what i said like you coming back
in my mind i'm like i'm not even paying
you no mind you're going to be right
back
it always happened it's cyclical this is
this is this is a break not a breakup
don't don't kid yourself
exactly we were on a break
for those who watch that reunion
recently
well what the hell oh i'm sorry yeah no
go ahead yeah no i was gonna say like
one thing i like
that she said was one in reference to
like that
the rare like items and ornaments like
you said yeah trials of the nine stuff
like that and that's the stuff
like i really miss a lot d1 had a lot of
that kind of stuff like
not that you should have been there but
like kind of stuff that was very hard to
obtain
and great show-off pieces that are not
in eververse so to speak right so i like
seeing that stuff what i was going to
ask you though is like
because again being that your history is
unique this is the first
game really and it's destiny and then
you know the online experience so it's
like
what was it for you was it what was the
initial hook was it the look was it
the gun play what was it just community
and being able to play with your friends
like mmo in the console space
i know the easy answer is all of them
but
my question is like which was the first
hook
that you're like man i really love this
about about destiny
i remember the first day that i played
the game
oh my god um it was a cosmodrome
just something about it it just took me
and like i spent so much time there like
just the first week like
you know you remember way back i mean
you that's all you could do really
but i remember that i i started out as a
hunter
just day one hunter and
i could i could technically use a
sparrow but i would literally
run everywhere now you can't you can't
make me all like sparrow six feet
i was six feet i'm like i'm not
okay
but then i like start like equally
playing my other characters you're like
oh you know what like am i really a mane
like i really love my warlock and then i
get into my titan i'm like yo titan's a
mood
i gotta be in the mood because that's a
mood
but it was the cosmodrome um and
ironically
when i first started destiny i was not
remotely as social as i am now
um it was either i play with that
roommate or
he wasn't my roommate at the time we
played for like a whole year he was in
new england i was in new york
and if he couldn't play then i was
basically by myself
just doing whatever um for the first
year of destiny all we did was play
control
that's all we did is played control and
i was always like at the bottom of the
leaderboard he was always at the top
occasionally i would be like
second place i could never like out frag
him yeah
yeah um but you know um
that was basically the first year and
then okay and then when i moved
uh moved here so i don't know what
happened but he
just like stopped playing destiny i know
him really well now so i'm just like i
don't even care but
he stopped playing destiny so it was
just me and
i had to branch out i had to figure it
out at that point
um you know we had mutual friends
that played destiny um just on a
different like platform like i had a
friend that did ps3 i was on ps4
he and i pitched it pitched the money
together to get her
ps4 and so i would play with her
he wasn't playing that often anymore and
so i went from one thing to another and
eventually
um i was raiding eventually wow
what was the first raid that you did i
got to cut you for a second what was the
first raid did you
attempt it uh i don't even i was bought
the glass it was vaulted glass
i felt i i i i fell off
do you remember that artwork of like
like atheon and you see the one guardian
falling that was me way back in the day
i just go yo how do you how did it wait
where did where did he get that
photograph that
actual photograph of me i'm not even
kidding
how was the how was the vlog jumping
puzzle with all those little platforms
did that treat you well or was that uh
that a bit of fun to this to this day i
hate jumping puffs
see you're really a warlock girl like
you you got a warlock
spirit no
no granted okay i spend so much time on
a war like that when i get on a hunter
and i make the jump i'm like
i forgot my stomping that's what
happened i forgot my stompies i put them
back on and i just
i'm the last one to get there like shut
up shut up
i'm always the last i know the feeling i
know that yeah
said the whisper mission i'm sure was
just your favorite things ever
oh totally totally quote unquote speed
speed running that
thing all that yeah okay
remember uh king's fall dick oh yep
and the pg rating is gone yeah we're
going and
actually the one the ship
the ship won before that used to get me
because it was that one specific
jump as you got further on what you had
to do you have to like clear the ship
basically i know what you're talking
about
used to terror and they would laugh at
me they'd all be on the other side
doing emotes cog's not here cod can't
make it he's a warlock and i'm like
oh man but did you ever make it to the
top of fell winter's peak either of you
yes i was proud of myself once and i
would never
i i'm not gonna lie i would never go
back and do it again
just the one time there you go yeah yeah
one time grab the fragment i'm done
you know ascending i hate it descending
i was fine
but yeah i trust you yeah i know the
feeling i know
what you got here oh man
but yeah um i also wanted to ask you
just as destiny has been your main game
what have been some of the highlights
over the course of like the franchise
we've got seven years what are a couple
just like two big standout moments that
you've had whether it's been on stream
just you and you know the friend on the
couch or
you know your friend and roommate before
like what are a couple moments that like
really cemented this franchise like took
it from this was amazing to like
almost jumping out of your chair through
the ceiling moment like what are a
couple of those just really cool ones
that you've been through because this is
your game so now i got to know what sits
at the top good point
i don't i don't even know if i can pull
a moment
other than like a couple moments that
just kind of showed me how far
i've come when i started this game i was
just like i have nobody to play with
um if people were mean to me i was like
oh look my internet went out
that person the anxiety was real
and i'd be like i'm out um
now it would take a lot for me to feel
that that kind of pressure
um what i would say is that top moments
uh would be
the two times that i've managed to uh to
clutch
a gm um they're not my strong suits
they're kind of uh i'm kind of
destination
uh [ __ ] at this point but um
yeah especially the uh the second
instance uh
i ended up in a 1v1 for 30 minutes with
the
proving grounds boss when he had like a
third health and
i have never felt so like terrified in
my life
yeah that'll keep you on the edge of
your seat for a minute yeah it was just
jumping back and forth with a sniper and
just just trying to focus up on
freaking out chat was on the they just
like
like i gotta go but i can't look away i
can't leave
and it was just the most intense moment
i've
ever had in this like game
um and then and i i managed to to
complete it and it was incredible
um the other one was another clutch but
it was like a
seventh dune song and uh
my partner saved he died our you know
our help had died right before him and
the shrieker is just railing me with
like the purple orbs and it's like
i i i am like i'm like two orbs away
from a well and i'm like i need this
wheel
oh and i'm just panicking uh
to get that well trying to shoot
anything at it because it's got like
micro health it's like come on like i
can't if we've been wiping for a while
like
we needed to complete this and i
basically traded with the with the
shrieker and we got the completion
and yeah we got this we got this person
their
uh their conqueror but it was just like
oh my god
yeah those are tough ones one of those
make it or break it moments
um but overall i would just say it's
like all the friends i made along the
way
it's just changed my life you know i
i tend to just adapt to the changes in
this game it's just so much more to me
than that it's it's what i
get away from my life to you know
you know what could be worse than what
doesn't make you happy
versus what just makes you feel like man
i'm coming home
literally yeah so it's like there aren't
like moments there's just
it's just a feeling it's it's it's it's
home there you go um that's awesome
yeah yeah i i know what you mean it's
one of those things it's like uh
you know the minute even if you i've
gone for a little while the minute you
fire up that title screen and you hear
the music and then you get it and you're
in space and it's just like
it says like i'm back i'm back you know
so i definitely hear that
one thing you mentioned there were i'm
sorry there were oh no it's fine
there were several there were there were
like maybe like a couple like dlc's that
were just like
they were just powerful i think we can
all agree that the taken king was just
like
there hasn't really been anything since
that's been that
that got huge like that hits home like
but i try not to hold on to like like
comparing everything to that
because it's almost like nothing will
ever amount to that
but i think that was a huge like turning
that that that
really turned everything around i think
that's when things
actually hit a new level and i was like
oh my god i'm really invested in this
game absolutely
absolutely like me and my roommate we
ran through that first mission
um and that that other friend she was on
ps3 we hadn't gotten her the ps4
the one we got her was actually the the
white destiny edition
so she got the really pretty one so she
wasn't there yet
but she's sitting on a on a skype call
right
with us just listening to us like
screaming and laughing because
we were getting booped there was like
the failings behind the door
you know surprises she had already done
it but
we were experiencing it for the first
time because we would work all day and
come home and like
it could be midnight and we're gonna be
up all night just
playing this game that was the thing we
did every single day we would just
hate our lives in the daytime and play
at night and that was our ritual
i love it i love it that i think that
was monumental to me like i
i i'm still friends with him i'm more or
less friends with her but that was a
huge
like oh wow this game just evolved
yes yes though like this is like i love
this
you're on fire you're on fire yeah i
kind of took that
kind of shaky start and then crota's in
people like i don't know it feels a
little short and people started beaming
on it
and then you know trials of osiris come
in start to make the pvp kind of really
hit and twitch started to grow
and then taking king was just like yeah
we're here and we're staying and it was
like that as you said the cement that
was like
it's gonna be here for the foreseeable
future
and they've stuck with it and it's kind
of one of those i have friends that
started with vault of glass played some
taken king but a lot of them have fallen
off and i've made so many like new great
friends met so many people on the
podcast my co-host now 152 episodes
later of course like but it's
it is it does have and i was working on
something yesterday
and somebody said it pretty well when
destiny comes and whenever it leaves
the community that it will have built
will be something that continues to last
yeah yeah and that's and that's just
something special so it's like
what it does for people is always
something different whether it's friends
that you make whether you start a
podcast where you've done a youtube
channel whether you've gotten a content
creation
whether it is just truly your escape or
you can go in
have fun you have friends to play with
outside of like
if your job day to day sucks and it's
but it's paying the bills but this is
what can balance that side of the
equation for you
those are some of the stories if bungie
ever hears these types of things that
those are the ones that probably hit him
the most as opposed to oh cool i started
youtube channel cool that's nice but
it's like
hey it's like this is my escape from
like a tough situation in life and this
is what gets me through it
those are the really true ones to hit so
that's that's awesome to hear yeah i
want to
double down too because on two parts one
the taking king part because
i agree completely what silva's saying
because
you know as a destiny fan you know
we kind of got ridiculed like oh it's
it's overrated and i don't know why you
like that game and the narrative's not
good and
all these different attacks i would get
for like why are you still
playing it and like taking can yeah game
is dead
like and take it king was the moment
that it validated destiny to the masses
because people at that point were like
oh no
this is amazing and then on top of that
you have this great you know
transition from the story into the
taking war
you know the the whole thing obviously
it was just
perfectly done and let's be honest like
it was
it was a clutch time like destiny you
know really needed that shot in the arm
to be taken seriously by the masses and
it came back in such full force i see my
entire friend list
playing that thing and then the second
thing i wanted to mention which he kind
of touched on
obviously is the community and what you
said silver and just like
you know it became an event like you log
on you you got that group that you play
with consistently
yeah and the feels and you know you're
learning about this person's day
like destiny is really about it is the
friend game i know the joke was like
is there but it is because you you you
it is you jump on
and it's just like again and then you
meet new people and so on and so forth
and to me again i know we do a destiny
podcast but
there's nothing like it it's just one of
the most unique
fun communal experiences and the
question that i'm leading to after me
rambling
was that sorry but
i did it too no it's funny it's funny
she got the emotions popping
but um yeah the question i had to ask
you was just like you know
from a community standpoint you said you
know a lot of it you know you're playing
going doing something in life that's
annoying you and then you come back
you're playing this game to kind of get
away like
what were some of those like friends and
and moments from a community standpoint
that meant a lot to you regarding this
it it's just it's strange because
there is no like linear uh
there's no way to like linearly track it
like i went from ps4 to pc
and that transition happened kind of
because i had no choice
like i kind of lost friends on ps4 and
pc was actually my final shot before i
quit destiny
actually i almost quit destiny because i
i at that point i couldn't handle
playing the game by
myself yes yes yes my former roommate
made a joke way
way way way back in the day and he's
like you ruined me i can't play this
game by myself
you ruined me i can't play this without
you and i'm like
i'm not sorry but um
pc was my shot i had a few people that
had moved on to pc the second it dropped
um and i started building from there i
started
uh being in twitch streams a lot like
it went from like almost like zero to
like 90 like i was suddenly like just
checking out streams like crazy
and actually you know meeting people you
know through their friends
like it like started with one person and
i just i guess i just met
all of his friends and i met their
friends and
from there i ended up on twitter and
it's just like
i'm just like i don't know how this
happened it's just incredible
um because the way it started was i was
just so
like socially awkward like to to the to
the extreme
i i would if i like like
look back i never would have thought
that any of this would have ever
happened
um this game has made it possible for me
to meet people that i
never would have met any other way you
know
especially given where i live it's like
really hard to meet people as it is so
the fact that i know people from
all over the world is incredible
i love it i can't wait to meet a good
chunk of them next year
like oh that'll be my first that'll be
my first uh convention actually oh it's
going
to be a lot of firsts we got a lot of
i was like it's the only game i know i
mean i guess warframe might have their
thing too but it's like it's the only
game i know that's had a convention
shout out to italian broman kevin all
those guys that started it and stuck
with it
that has just like exploded and they've
made it a huge event down there but man
2019 when we went and you know podcast
wasn't that old
we've had how i don't even know how many
episodes since the number of guests that
we've had the number of people that
we've actually
got a chance to talk to it's like
there's not going to be enough time in
the entire trip down there to
have a decent conversation station with
everybody we've had on because it's been
so
much fun so that's that's my biggest
fear is that i'll be like yo where you
at let's meet up let's get a drink let's
do this
shamelessly i was like i shamelessly
wore my bantu shirt and it helped so
yeah like i'm probably gonna do the same
thing but i'm probably gonna be like yo
somebody's gonna have to keep track of
me down there because i'm gonna be like
oh my god oh my god oh my god everywhere
but i mean that's the fun part like if
you see somebody
they can chat just chat away the funny
the funny part is i probably
will be like oh my god is that is that
glad i can't go say i didn't glad i
can't do it
one thing i will say is you have one
chance to say hi to people and you just
like oh god i'm shy i can't do this
i mean i was like believe me i've i have
busted on my shell over the course of my
life so far but i was like
he's come a long way
i was much worse y'all he met me trust
me growing up it was terrible but that's
one of those things like
i i don't think anybody i met there was
anything but ultra nice
so i was like oh i i 100 but i was like
take the second
shake their hand it mean you may not
have that much time people get swamped
and stuff like that but
everybody was ultra nice and awesome to
say hello to so it's like just take the
second
and do it and if they gotta run they
gotta run but it's still worth just to
say
hey at least i got to meet you and say
hello and thanks for doing all that you
do whatever it is
it's ultimately something that
you know would not have happened if all
of these things didn't come together to
just bring you to this moment
like yeah it's incredible
you know it's like i would never would
have met you i wouldn't even know
who you are i i do remember
for years it's ironic um i wanted to get
into gaming
and my parents just wouldn't buy me uh
you know a console they wouldn't buy me
anything and i would be like
i would ask my friends like what should
i get should i get like a ps4 a
playstation or an xbox and
i could never get a straight in so i
realized that i realized why now
yeah so i was like if i can't get a
straight answer or a way for me to
figure out what i want then it's like
not even worth looking into
um and it wasn't until someone literally
was like yo get this and i'm like
he has four that's what i'm getting that
was the place to go that was the place
to go
actual connection that i'm like okay
that's it that's this is where i'm gonna
start
um i did get an xbox eventually in uh
indy one and i was running i was running
trials on
on like two platforms and it it got a
little crazy
you know for a while this is pre-cross
save days
god i know oh salute to you
that's
lent it to my friend and never got it
back but the point being
yeah it's complicated
but yeah it's kind of sad i wish i had
it now but
you know crossplay is coming i mean
could you ever imagine that
oh me either me either so yeah
that's that's awesome so i mean destiny
has been
a big piece for us but to be your first
game
and you picked a good one to start with
um yeah and also i mean you've been
through the bumps in the road you almost
lost and then pc
and then just the journey you've been on
from this one game as your only game
i don't know if any other game is going
to live up to this so just remember that
when you step out to other things and be
like
some of these they're going to be
smaller shorter not the legs not as cool
you're going to have to experiment a
little more because yeah destiny set the
bar kind of high with everything it's
been doing
it it did i i'm well aware of that it
that's why when people go like oh hey
like you should play this you know every
time a game comes out
and people go like yo you should play
this i just go like ah
i'm gonna fall behind on season she's
like i'm good
i'm good like i'm like you know like
sometimes friends will be like what if i
buy it for you please don't do that
because i don't feel bad that i
definitely don't want to
[Laughter]
sit there oh man i'll be like oh god
please don't spend the money but no i
absolutely know that i'm completely
spoiled because
and just from being where i am watching
everybody else
just like you know whenever they get
frustrated with this game like the pvp
community they get frustrated and they
want to quit and move on to another game
they don't find what they
what what they've experienced here
anywhere else and that's why
they don't leave they actually come back
because
we're all addicted you know it is what
it is we as long as we
own it we're fine i i did i did kind of
find
um there was another game that was a
single player that i did enjoy
a lot for some reason it had a similar
destiny feel at least to me it did um
and
at one point i actually didn't want to
play destiny just as much
i don't remember why um i got into
infamous second son
oh yeah and it just had a good it had
good movement and a good feel
i never finished it but it was you know
it was great and i got pretty far
into it but um yeah that was like
probably the only time that i
experimented
between that and the division these are
games that kind of like okay like i can
see myself
dedicating time to this however you know
with a
full-time job and maybe essentially like
full-time streaming really because i
enjoy it so much
uh i can't share destiny's space with
another
oh it's very selfish it's hard oh it's
very selfish
i've missed out on a lot and with some
of the way the seasonal model's been
it's given me a chance to play other
stuff and i've enjoyed the variety
um but i was like there was a time or it
was just mostly it so for me it's been
healthier
as it has been seven years and a lot of
things to like get a little variety for
a mix but every time
the variety has helped destiny continue
to feel a bit more fresh
which i've enjoyed when i do pop it back
in on tuesday and expunge
hits like with a new mission or i play
for a little while it's not just like um
i'm you know bashing my head against the
wall for a while after seven years like
little breaks are good so it's like
we've said that like
weeks and months and years at this point
it's like the points where it does feel
a little long
take a little break try something else
and then when you come back it's to hit
hit a little bit better just
it may need to breathe for a second
especially for the people yeah
that's all angry but getty i'm sorry no
i was just going to say we got
some things that have happened this week
yeah we got some things to talk about so
first one quick i do want to just like
literally blow through the twab because
it's not much iron banner is coming back
and your tokens are going to work
correctly
this time so you guys are going after
the the new machine gun the new shotgun
um and trying to farm for those finish
up the quest
that will be accessible on tuesday the
8th so
that will be going for the week so if
you're trying to get some new rolls i do
like the way those weapons look
the new the new ones the styling the the
tan coloring the wraps and stuff just
i liked what they did with those that
was pretty cool uh they also did have a
big giant fashion show on the swab so
check out some people who had a lot of
fun with their gear
um transmog doing its thing outside of
the whole transmog
farming issue that we all know takes
probably way too long
the appearance screen and the way you
can toy around with everything and
really look at what's there has been
really nice to see
yeah a couple of the quick updates they
did a photo sensitivity notice just for
anybody who's like light sensitive to
flashes or anything
that's a nice thing to see them put in
the front of the game seen a couple
people specifically call that one out
uh they also mentioned for the
teleporting enemies update they are
actually
looking to basically increase the
bandwidth of their servers
so hopefully that's a little less they
said it's not gonna
cause that to be completely eliminated
but working with servers trying to get a
little more bandwidth for
data and access and things of that
nature supposed to help that a little
bit
they did also touch on the pc
performance update
it kind of comes down to developing at
home
they don't did not have their basically
their
pc configuration like test rigs and all
that they had before to make sure things
were as
because pcos has an infinite number of
combinations you put parts together it's
going to be different even if it's just
one
so they didn't have their specific setup
at the studio to be able to do all this
so testing from home they did what they
could
but that's where the issues have been
coming from specifically on pc it's
more for some people less of an issue
for others they're continuing to do
optimizations but it's
they i think they wanted to it's nice to
see them address that i just
they are slowly doing iterations to it
but the main reason was
they didn't have their previous
situations before so it made some sense
makes sense of the pandemic it actually
i'm glad they said that i didn't
what it is we forget you know that in
the background what they're dealing with
you know with the type of issues but
yeah that's good to know
uh but yeah we gotta talk about the big
bomb that dropped
the stasis nerfidge into some of it into
the ground
some of it good bad and others so i
wanted to get you guys thoughts if you
had a chance to play
if what you've heard what the
community's saying so far
how is the world of the changes of
stasis the hot fix that happened
yesterday
has been hidden how's it feeling have
you played any pvp
where are you guys sitting at right now
with stasis and typically pvp side of
things
we had silva did you get a chance to
jump in
um admittedly i've been playing
uh if i had to do crucible i've been
playing mainly uh momentum control so
i feel like i've stayed like out of it
but
everything that i have heard is like oh
yeah stasis is basically
dead and i'm like okay so y'all are
happy now right
i don't wanna i don't have to hear
hashtag uh nerf stasis
whatever you know whatever the hashtag
was i'm like y'all are happy now like
everybody seems to say that crucible is
now playable again like
you know they can jump back in and i'm
like okay like
they seem to be happy they're all like
asking each other like you know
like can i come back should i come back
is it worth coming back
and i'm like and i'm just sitting here
like oh my god
oh my god they seem happy and if they're
not then it's like i don't know what you
want
man um but i i've been having fun
playing laser tag that's just me i'm
very simple
oh momentum control laser tag that's all
that's in there
yes i i'm just very simple prometheus
lens bring it back to that one weekend
where
prometheus lens was broken that was a
fun
weekend so i get a reminder of that um
and so i just go in there and i'll do my
pinnacle and uh
and just have fun um i'll see you
yeah i'm gonna i'll be defer to you e
because um
i have not got a chance to touch the pv
people i should sense the nerf
but you know i'm hearing things i'm
hearing things but uh
have you uh jumped in at all or what
have you heard
i was busy with something yesterday so i
didn't get a chance to jump in
host packs but from what i gathered from
tweets from a lot of the high level pvp
guys
and we'll get to the big firing range
stuff a little bit later
um but general tweets i'm seeing from a
lot of people
uh some people said hey i went through a
match and i got frozen
like once or twice in five matches or
something and i'm seeing stuff like that
which is hopefully as you said silver
what everybody seems to be going for
uh i know the major changes are
high level changes are just about the
freeze the non-super freezes you
honestly can't break out of them they're
so short i see people almost still like
sliding through some of the abilities
um basically unless it's a super freeze
which still should be substantial your
super should still be
yeah a noticeable thing that you gotta
work for and should have some
weight to it the normal freezes the
abilities the shurikens the melees
that stuff is going to be much less the
slower is you know less accuracy flinch
the movement speeds a little less like
when you read through all of that stuff
it does seem
substantial and then from what i'm
seeing on twitter there seems to be a
decent amount of positivity and i don't
know if it's like 100
there okay um but it definitely seems to
be this is the biggest
chunk that they've done like they they
kind of brought a couple
abilities down for certain classes like
big outliers
started with the warlocks then some
hunter and then some titan they kind of
went through this is
the bigger overall really reeling it in
to try and see how it feels in
comparison to the light subclasses
right and then when i see pictures on
twitter of almost all light subclasses
in pvp in a match and you're just like
completely floored like there's not a
lot of stasis
it's different so okay okay so
i'm sorry yeah no it's like my one worry
is that hopefully these effects were
mostly
focused to pvp right because the crowd
control effects and stasis overall has
never been like
op and pve stasis has never been that
crazy in pve it has some crowd control
it has some support
my titan especially has never felt like
the super is great in pve
like it really doesn't feel the warlock
seems nicer to spread and yeah burst
damage and stuff yeah
a lot yeah my sadly like my titan has
never been
feeling because it's like you got to do
the slam and then you got to break the
crystals i'm just trying to like
it never feels like it gets as much so
that's why i was like i haven't played
stasis that much since it came out
really
i haven't even been farming the
fragments and everything that much just
because i've been enjoying the other
classes a bit more because i do more pve
uh yeah but as for like the hunters and
stuff especially for you silver
how much stasis have you been using even
in pve or pvp
is it like part of your you know bag
that you use or have you been
you know not as big on it where have you
been with stasis so far
admittedly i i i'll remain in a variety
um i i'll use goldie i'll use spectral
i tend to neglect arcstrider like 100
but i'll play the other three depending
on how i'm feeling but i try to stay
off of stasis partially because of the
perception and i don't want to get too
attached to it
uh overall um i do
like the the shatter dive movement and
that's mainly why i like it i don't
really like the super itself i just
like the movement um but i would i would
mainly play
uh spectral or or goldie um i like those
two
the most especially since i goldie's a
lot in d1 so it's like man like i
haven't like
properly done this in so long um
but i've also been playing other
characters um i've been on my warlock a
lot and i've
like i've been basically crutching chaos
reach i'm not even gonna lie
yeah i've been so far from stasis that
it's almost like
i haven't been like living in this
quote-unquote problem
um in terms of in terms of stasis like
it can be very annoying or it could be
very annoying
but it would just be like all right next
game and i would just queue up the next
game and move on from there
in pve it was just so
so helpful and that is also my biggest
fear that you know
the changes are not separate and it's
going to be something that you're not
going to choose to use in a grand master
especially since that's coming up and
you know right that's that's where i'm
going to be like 100
um and if you know stasis is like not
really going to be as helpful like
that's going to be
kind of big sad like i'm i'm hoping that
that's not the case
um yeah but from what i've seen so far
um a lot of the things that people
complained about are just not effective
anymore like shurikens
it's just not remotely the same it's
just not the same
um movement can counter
you know the slowing effects which is
what people wanted people wanted you to
be able to just dodge right out of it
you know so if you were quick enough to
do it you could just get out of it um
and i can see why people would not
choose stasis once they realize like wow
i
i literally can't trap you anymore no
if i like throw this at you i better
follow that up with something that'll
kill you instantly because
you know otherwise it's like i did it
for nothing um yep
uh but titan seems to be the most
affected from what i've uh from what
i've heard and from what i've seen and
people seem to be happy
they seem to be happy you know yeah like
ascendant nomad has a tweet basically
stasis feels like a conscious choice to
use and feels completely alien from how
it used to be before with strengths
and in capital letters and weaknesses
that means that they
uh there could very well be a skill gap
emerging with the subclass itself it's
no longer
free and that's a win i think it's the
i think it finally and if you listen to
fire team um
yeah whole
yeah go watch that episode watch the
last one their last like they may come
back for sporadic ones but it's their
last name
weekly show so check that out but also
um firing range with fallout cool guy
merc and all those guys
um drewski and cammy sorry i got them
all and they had two of the bungee guys
on there and they went through
it was like two hours and 45 minutes
it's a long one and they got a lot of
information out
and kevin yonas one of the sandbox leads
pretty much stated
at first they started stasis building it
up to say
hey we want to you know freeze you but
then it was it was frozen but you
basically didn't do much damage to them
so then they kept beefing it up and
beefing it up beefing it up and then by
the time it basically got ready for
launch it was so strong
they knew it going out the door that it
had to get reeled back in so they knew
before it launched
but again there's also development
cycles and testing and figuring out
works to work on bringing it back down
so
it is a time sink for them to do it both
ways and unfortunately there's a point
of
how did it get so far right before it
got reeled back in or how did it get
released and be like
you know can you do like just a minus 10
on everything button like do something
if they knew it was that busted
so they did acknowledge like yes this is
a little too strong before it came out
so they knew this stuff was coming um i
think they were trying to figure out
what was gonna settle into the meta what
things were gonna be the really big
outliners and they nailed those a little
quicker closer to beyond light
but they also said they've learned a lot
we all have a hunch there's going to be
future subclasses we don't know but we
have a feeling there may be
and while they didn't confirm them
because the snipers would have shot him
on
on stream directly they did
basically state that the launch of
stasis itself
is something they really said they've
learned a lot from and they want to
make sure that as things come out in the
future either they have maybe
and it's you know you can speculate but
it's like maybe there's quicker ways to
change it maybe it's built in a way that
they can do quicker adjustments or
kind of go through and realize maybe
more testing whatever is needed but they
definitely have
learned in stasis's launch because
community's been up in arms and only
building up until this point so
hopefully it does feel a little bit
better
yeah but um yeah that's a really good
list and also as well firing range that
was last night yeah
they uploaded it everywhere fast because
it was so so requested so it's out there
but it does seem
um stasis is not what it was
so go check out pvp momentum controls
its own animal you don't even see
abilities in there it's all laser beams
and
other stuff but uh normal pvp will be
curious to see the feel of trials this
weekend
cheaters is one thing that's a different
animal but stasis abundance and trials
i'll be very curious to watch twitter
this weekend and see how it goes
yeah well i wanted to jump in um yeah
that's actually good great information
here that you you caught that from
firing so to them that that's
really informative i did not realize
that um yeah i got to jump in with pvp i
do play pvp a lot and i want to see
how you know it is but i try if you're
saying nomad is making shout out to
nomad because i really
respect his opinion and a lot a lot of
other people in pvp community
if they're saying look it got that work
it's been brought down
you know you know it's now in line and
requires more of a skill gap as opposed
to an easy
win with certain certain situations
certain abilities i'm for that for me
i got a confession on pve i
love stasis and pve i like since
this has come out i ain't gonna lie
silver like
i've been shade binding warlock like
crazy like i love frost pulse with the
um
the my rift that freezes i i love the um
the other one the uh the one that you
make the little buddies
yeah the butt yeah
when what you call it comes out that you
know the the harpies and all that stuff
comes out with the templar phase
like when you when you're defending the
confluxes i got traps and then
i got a thing where you know i get my
finisher back i get my grenade back and
i absolutely it is really good
at difficult content as far as um
nightfalls as well so
yeah i've been i've been crutching on
you know what i mean that term
the term that they use was basically uh
giving you a chance to breathe
yes yep it it gives that to you so if
you take that away it's like
man so that brings me back to the whole
like when they mentioned we have no
intention
of separating pvp and pve sandboxes and
i was like
okay but i really hope that you're not
ruining
we're not ruining but you're not
bringing it down so far that now this is
not viable for pve
and how do you create a balance that
right can appease both sides
yeah that's the question right because
my my for my understanding
the these nerves for the most part seem
to be affecting pvp
but again i need to jump in there test
it again
see what's going on because i remember
in the past when they did make some
changes to mache binder i was like hold
on
you know my melee thing don't feel as
good in pve you know and certain things
didn't feel as good so i
definitely want to see what it is but i
definitely want to shout out because i i
do
love it in pve it it's to me it's a ton
of fun
and it's like you said it gives you that
chance to breathe especially when things
are overweight and especially the uh
aspect that when you i have the one
where you freeze one
when they die it seeks out another one
and you can chain it and start doing
crazy and the new build now with the
shards that give you off
give you armor like pve you could get
really
crazy so i want to see i'm going to
really put it through its paces this
week now that the uh
the nerf is is out on pvp and then also
test to make sure my
my pve is good just make sure i'm okay
it's hard to know for sure because like
for example
um i haven't used it in the raid it's
just not what i use
uh i actually had to do a raid for my
hunter so i definitely
really i would i wouldn't use it on a
hunter but you you're just
there's just no real like difficult
difficult content to yeah
to try it out on like if gm's were out
right now you'd you just you'd go out
right now and and test it test to test
it see how
how different it feels uh last season uh
stasis had us had a special role where
something's affected by stasis
it it gives you a buff you know uh
uh you know if you were to use a goldie
any light you know uh subclass
you know you got a buff you did more
damage yep um i forgot what that was
called oh my god i know what to talk
about yeah i know what you're talking
about yeah yeah so
you know stuff like that like i just
hope to not see
you know those possibilities reduced
right
in the future because they did mention
that this patch wasn't even supposed to
come out right now they
put a rush on it and yes you know a tiny
part in a
tiny voice in the back of my head kind
of like i really hope that in trying to
appease the community to bring this asap
that we didn't
uh kind of hurt ourselves down the line
on other changes that might need to
happen i mean they did warn us like
don't expect this
to happen like like emergency patches
because this was
you know we really pushed to make this
happen um so
you know they they do care they do care
good point
you know no absolutely absolutely and
like i said
we have to see how this thing plays out
but you know absolutely yeah so far so
good
what else we got here uh one other thing
that came from firing range yesterday
seemed to spark a little bit of
contention
um there were different takes and there
were different uh
thoughts about this one and it seems to
be
that it
when it comes to deep stone crypt the
strategy that started to pop
out was um shout out to king allen thank
you for stopping
um all of you a lot of people really got
into the double slug shotgun meta
yeah that started to be used with
divinity especially
and then for is it tanix i'm even not
even think i'm
getting the net is that 10x the boss
okay yeah you're good
yeah um so that started to you to have
that one
and then it's the idea of um
basically you know the quick switching
of the weapons to continually fire and
pump out the highest dps and then
there's this like
reload quote glitch some people say it's
glitch some people say it's skill
um and that was actually addressed in
the podcast and they said what do you
think about this you know quick switch
or quick swapping glitch per se or
whatever you call it
and they said well since quickdraw has
been removed since for shotguns and that
kind of piece is there
then we're really at a point to where
we're probably going to be looking at
that and
it really seemed to spark a lot of
attention because
some people were really kind of annoyed
that a high skill ability
or something that you can eventually
learn how to do learn how to
quick swap weapons yeah you're sprint
canceling and that's why some people
called it a glitch and then some people
were like
you've been able to do this in basically
first person shooters for years and
years and years
right it's not new to destiny it's just
a way to hit a button to cancel an
animation
and then be able to basically do things
quicker so
some people practice it and get good at
it i've seen people on controller
i saw somebody who um i think he was
using like
i'm not one of those people
you'll see me awkwardly go from one
shotgun to the other to the other to the
other two it's it's almost embarrassing
but i'm not one of those people and it's
like don't
don't make fun of me i'm using a double
shotgun i'm doing my best she's like
i'm doing my part
i'm honestly just too lazy to learn it
you know it might be a skill thing or
it's just like why why do i need to do
all that
and that's one of those things and but
some of that stuff is stemmed from
people trying to do low man raids and
truly having to go
as efficient as possible and they're
gonna figure these things out
i mean shout out to chiefs forever shout
out to chevy glad the guys who really go
hard on the low man's the solos there's
certain things they have to try and do
just to make those things happen and
glad had a
pretty decent little thread yeah yeah
and i had sent over
yeah uh that i sent it to you directly
yeah i did
i'm gonna leave out a couple of the
choice words to you guys but i want to
read it you gonna leave out the spice
the spice will be beeped um
so every time bungie removes tech like
slug shotgun swapping
and izzy for example like is an august
burden they're slowing down the game
aren't they trying to move away from
that in both pvp and pve they are
stripping away the reward from players
who put in practice
let people master your game leaving that
word out
um what it's like what's this not
accessible to everyone he's hearing
you can literally swap shotguns and
sprint on every platform
and input device can't do it well tough
practice
uh the mental that mentality is not
great it's like if
if all can't do it then you can't either
swapping weapons and sprint canceling
has been around for ages and shooters
it's basic stuff if you put slug
shotguns in both kinetic and energy
slots
people will abuse them and maybe if
bosses didn't stand there during the dps
phase and say shoot me
you'd see less of it stop calling on a
glitch it's not a glitch
so kept it clean um
but that's the idea is and this honestly
like almost stems back to
you know the sakura for what like i'm a
huge souls player since i started my
first one i'm hooked i can't stop
playing them
played mega man got my you know got my
head just crushed and mentally just like
every time you lost you're like
start the whole level over got to learn
it but it was
mega man in itself is a short game
where's the length is learning the game
and overcoming the difficulty so
same principle applies here so like they
try and make raids and they walk a
delicate line contest is going to be a
harder version you got to be a little
more efficient or really beyond to be
able to make it through damage phases
but you also have a point where they're
trying to make raids somewhat not
completely awful for
a decent amount of people i mean still
you know 15 20 percent of people may be
a high number that do raids
but they don't want to make them
completely awful for everybody and
master aids may be the option to that
but when it comes to the higher skill
choices the higher skill abilities and
things like that
long intro aside i was honestly you guys
curious just overall in your gaming
history and hearing about this and then
things about sakura
do you think stuff like this should be
like taken away do you think it should
be left in there
do you think things like this give
people something to strive for or do you
think it's a way for people like to
abuse the game
so i wanted to get you guys thoughts
just does i mean gaming in general for
one of our audience is just destiny like
cognito and i have played a lot of games
over the years but either way it's still
the idea of
how much time and practice do you need
to put be put in to be good
and how high should the skill ceiling
actually be how much
is there to strive for or how much
should there be
silver what are your thoughts because i
mean you sit there and run grandmasters
all the time
there's people who don't even think
about those so again when it comes to
learning things and pve like you can
learn but it's like
even skills and stuff like that what are
your thoughts just on you know skill
ceilings and abilities like this and
just
functions in the game believe it or not
i
i do run gm's uh as soon as they come
out
until like until they're done um i've
actually looked at the stats like oh how
many completions do i have and
i don't know if you've ever seen that
website i remember what it's called but
i've looked at it
it shows you completions time spent your
quickest gm
how many attempts so failed attempts and
i'll look at that number and be like
holy crap we actually wiped that many
times
and so there is a massive learning curve
until
you know me and sabe get it down to
where people are going holy crap how are
we flying through this
um there's been like maybe like a couple
where it was just not as easy you know
easy breezy but
we end up learning the timing on on all
the enemy waves and how to
systematically just bring out the
enemies like people
think that it's hard it is hard but it's
like if you're
letting everything just fly loose you're
gonna get overwhelmed you're gonna die
um for example uh fall and saber
we would just we would he actually
figured this out not me
uh the the warsaw at the beginning part
yes there are three different points
where you have to get off to spawn
each champion you kill each champion you
move to the other side
then you bring up the timer again bring
out the next champion take care of that
and so you're literally killing things
in waves
without overwhelming yourself and it's
it's just systematic and and that's how
you just
get through it right um and we have to
figure these things out usually he
figures him out more than me but once i
get into the rhythm of just like the
timing
you know i make less mistakes i actually
i still make plenty of mistakes but
ultimately make less mistakes and you're
able to bring someone through that needs
help because that's the ultimate goal is
to
help people i tend to look at it as more
like i'm going to be in
i'm going to be living in his gm's
whether you know whether you play with
me or not
but you may i may as well help you while
you're while we're at it especially
since now there are weapons that people
want to farm
right um like palindrome last season
that was a that was a big one that was a
very big one especially for
double pally oh yeah um
so i think that there should be uh you
know
it should be rewarding for people that
actually put in the time you know some
people will be like oh it's too hard i
don't want to do it and then they just
don't do it
right um in in
in the case of the uh quick draw glitch
i you know i i know what tweet you're
talking about so i like you know i
did read through the whole thread and i
do remember
you know him saying that and i do
remember
thinking you know he wants people to be
able to master the game
you know because people like him have in
a way mastered the game
right and it is kind of uh a strange way
of thinking that if you know if not
everybody can do it then
you know then nobody should do it right
um there should be people that are at
the top
and i feel like people like him have
inspired people to get you know
you know take a chance and actually do
low man activities i don't know if this
is something that i've noticed more over
the you know the last year or so
but more people want to do low man's
more than ever people are going
going in they're getting it done and and
and you know and it's fantastic
um i have not personally done it but
it's because of people like him and if
you're taking
yeah if you're taking these things away
you know it just it makes it a lot
harder overall for everybody it could be
even more discouraging for people
wanting to
you know get something like a
two-three-man completion you know
under their belt it might just be one of
those things where it really is only
possible for the best of the best but
like do you want to necessarily put that
so out of reach that
like nobody can do it no i i don't see
the harm in the glitch to be honest
um yeah i i think somebody else
mentioned that it's not necessarily the
glitch
it's more like why can you do damage to
a boss at such close proximity without
consequence
so i don't know i i really don't know
i i don't i don't know what the answer
is you're making great points though
you're still making great points and a
lot of stuff that you said
resonates with me i'll jump in um this
is
interesting this is a good one you
brought to the campfire sir i
must commend you this was something i
did not catch that
now that i'm seeing what's going on i'm
seeing the stir
in the community seeing everyone getting
up in arms and
you know what you know the more i
thought about it and i was like
the signs were on the wall for me e
you never if you gonna remember this it
was me
you and scarole when we did um
garden and we jumped in and killed
megatron i called it megatron yeah
i know exactly what you're talking about
at the time
izanagi was the rage izzy was the rage
that you needed izzy
is it aggies bird to get that thing done
if you had that catalyst you was in you
was in pocket everybody in the raid team
wanted you
that first thing that you guys see and
remember the thing with izzy
was you know the four clip reload
into the big the big bullet and yeah
that
was a thing and i shout out to scouring
them guys they had that canceling
animation thing that they
figured out right to be able to shoot
faster to get dps cycle
and to really help and drag people
through
right so to me it's it's not
a glitch like it because it it to me
it's still a skill thing it's still
they're able to find this thing and yeah
i guess you could say it's an exploit i
guess
but i don't look at it as a glitch i
don't i look at is not only very few
people can do it
and you know this is how they're able to
do the content
the problem is this seems to always
butt heads with bungie's philosophy as
far as
melting things right they just do not
like us melting things they do not
they've shown time and time again they
they want to do that and
i have to admit i i kind of thought i
was glad on this man because it's like
you know i'd always be glad all the time
i'll be honest but with this
i do agree with him you know i'm saying
because you know i feel like
the low man's like like you said and and
this very difficult content and if the
content creators are able to do this
stuff to stay alive and
and then it's like like silva said a lot
of this
inspires others to try these type of
activities
now if you keep cutting the legs off of
the hardcore like let's be real
since they did that to izzy who's really
using izanagi lately
i mean yeah it's
it ain't at the top of the list yeah and
this is this it really isn't
it's a it's a do you have that like but
yeah there's just
many other things that you could make an
exotic
rather bring anarchy and xeno into the
picture
than than izanagi at this point
especially
like anarchy with reaching clear which i
am totally guilty of doing like
literally
all the time right um i'm a bad sniper
so i would definitely that was never on
the izanagi trying to begin with but
i'm telling you you can poke a punch but
if you missed that shout out
yeah you were hurt but especially now
that it's such a hassle to
you know yeah it's just not yeah
it's not useless but it's not what it
used to be it's not what it used to be
and to me that's when i get frustrated
because i look at things like that i
look at things like sleeper once
dominant weapons that somehow because
of what they consider people using an
exploit or whatever
that now you know it's not going to get
you so
it's frustrating because i like to see
these great race strategies being
implemented
i like shout out to back for dead he's
in there he's part of my ray team you
know
i i love to see that stuff it's skill i
like to see
esoteric in those guys i like to see
that stuff because to me
like you said silver it's almost
inspiration wow that could be done
and now you get into like well let me
let's try it let's you know i'm not
gonna lie
so a raid will come out right contest
modifier will come and go
next day it's been two-manned yeah
yeah facts fast it's it's i almost
expected it at this point i almost
expected it's like yep mm-hmm
that's what i'm talking about you know
but these
are the masters this is what they do
this is what they
enjoy they enjoy a specific
challenge right that i feel like
once upon a time people didn't even
think about doing that right
but it says has been going on since d1
you know people
soloing you know right rate encounters
the same people in a way but now
more people are doing it yeah um
sometimes you have to break the game to
make that happen otherwise it's like
right you know yeah the last part i'm
gonna say is just that
yeah i look at the result and the result
is you're was you're reloading faster
right yeah yeah you know i don't feel
you do i mean yeah she's gonna
overall extend your dps yes well now i'm
not gonna say it's not
but at the end of the day i don't feel
like this is oh my god you're
breaking again you're completely we're
not pushing anything on off a ledge
you know so we're not doing something
that's that's so destroying the
integrity of the encounter
that it is now you know i can i can
understand bungee jumping i i just don't
see it as that you know
it's like okay i'm reloading i'm doing
something to reload a little faster
that's just me but i'm gonna give it
back to you like where where are you at
with this now that this is
raging throughout the community i think
the i think the
um even even with these quote unquote
glitches people are not
easily clearing these it's not like
everybody's two manning three manning
like
oh
it's still very difficult a lot of
people just don't want to
they they're not challenged by that um
for example
like people are different you know they
just want different challenges
uh say you know my partner he has solo
gms i have honestly as much as i love
love love gms i have no interest in
doing that i feel like it's like i don't
need to do that i don't need to
wrestle through that and if i do then
then you know i i mean i know it's
possible
um right you know but that's just
something that if you really seek
you know seek to do that for yourself
then you can you know take on that
challenge the same thing with like low
manning you know it almost makes no
sense it's like oh you know why not just
bring in a group of friends like no
that's just
that's what just some people want they
just they want that
challenge right last point i'm gonna
give that to you it's not hurting
anybody
you know not for you last point yeah i'm
gonna give out don't be talking a lot
now the thing i was going to say is that
also how they can
rectify i think sad free cedrine and um
destiny show they're all in the corners
and they're saying some good points is
that
to me if if they're so against this
right
if you look at your raid challenges
there's things that they say hey
like you want to do to beat the temple
or do it make the templar move four
times instead of you one phase
you said i'm saying like you can put you
can now utilize the challenge
modes and the harder modes to still get
your intended
effect if you're if you're bungie and
you're so angry
that they're doing this reload thing as
opposed to taking it away
so this way there's still ways to strive
to get
and give reward to the way you want
quote unquote the encounter done
mechanically so to speak from a from a
developer standpoint
and to me it everybody's happy you said
i'm saying because
the people who want to just play it
regular and do what they want to do are
fine
and then bungee's like hey we'll give
you this great reward this challenge
this title
this shader this weapon or whatever
for doing the challenge morning i think
everyone kind of wins but i'll give it
to you
like i'm very curious to see what you
think about all this man
no i mean i'm gonna be in a similar boat
to you guys
and i mean it comes from playing stuff
like souls games and that giant debate
of what is too hard
and i actually listened to a good
podcast i cannot remember
it could have been kind of funny and
somebody else or
i don't know um but it was talking about
the difference of difficulty versus
accessibility
right and that's a huge difference in
difficulty like as you guys are talking
about low man's and challenges and
master modes are gonna come later the
way grandmasters feel
um versus allowing people to play
content and experience it at all
depending on
you know some people have like you know
there's vision things and there's color
blind and then sound and
there's so many and then shout out to
xbox for their controller that allows
people to play games that might not be
able to otherwise
be adapted all those different things
are
different ways for people to access a
game that doesn't mean they don't want
the challenge
same thing tends to apply here is people
want the challenge
but they also need to be able to have
some tools to be able to face that
challenge
so um
it's one of those things where
to me like this type of thing as you
said it's
not pulling pulling an internet cable
it's not
you know pushing these guys off a ledge
it's not that type of stuff those are
ones where it's like
yeah that needs to fix because
somebody's grabbing the relic somebody's
blocking it and you're doing damage
faster
those are the times where the arbitrary
damage faces and every time
i see the hollowed lair strike pop up it
bugs the hell out of me because you know
there's like
is it seven eight nine damage like
phases that you've got to go through in
that thing and it's just arbitrary in a
normal strike that's 1100
that you could know you could nuke him i
mean they put something like curious
your ass or whatever it is of the fallen
star in the game you have celestial
nighthawk now you have breach and clear
that makes that
even more so it's like they put things
in there that do insane amounts of
damage i'm like you know eating to
you know atheon at this point still
going back and popping my damage and
flying one more time if i could do it
fast enough
and if you do it at the start of atheon
the way your super comes back you can do
it twice
yeah you can do it like you can get a
crap that that stuff they seem to be
okay with
but then like the reload glitching is
something they feel like they need to
get after but they make stuff that does
when i see 462 000 damage on my screen
from my super i'm like that's a lot
that's more than most things so it's
like i know it's a bunch
so it's like the it's weird what they
tackle first off yeah but it's like some
of chat saying he's like
it is nice to see gto said it's like
they enjoy watching those things happen
you watch somebody that they're like the
people on twitch are usually three
skill entertainment or
you know kind of a freaky combination of
both
where you know and it's like and then
there's one other one i'm forgetting
because i heard somebody describe it
once really well it's like you need to
be insanely skilled
you could say nothing but if you're like
you know going off in every war zone
match and you and everyone people are
going to watch because that's insane
um people can be entertaining you could
watch somebody be the worst person in a
game but if you're laughing having a
good time
cool and then there's also probably
going to be like the informative and
some mix of all of those and the lucky
ones have all of that going on and those
ones that tend to get to the top
so those are kind of those things where
it seems like a weird decision coming
from playing difficult games from mega
man 3
to you know shout out to one of my
favorites and then you know good old
super mario not the longest game but a
lot of people probably didn't make it
past world you know two or anything like
that like the first game
so it's like mario's not an easy game
people go back and be like man this is
rough it's like yeah
all of that stuff is always going to be
there so when it comes
all the way full circle to this it's
just like i don't
see reload speed and especially some
things that's been around in
first-person shooters for
freaking ever if that's one of those
things they feel like they need to
tackle but i can
go after a boss with a flying super that
does so much more damage and tack on
breach and clear
or you can tag them with stasis so you
do more damage and you come from a well
all of that stuff combines is stuff that
they built in the game but then the
reload shotgun thing
they built yeah yeah they built that in
and it's kind of
those are the ones yeah contra is
another one all those are just insane so
it's like the difficulty
people find ways to make the game
difficult with low man's and everything
else
so it's like this little thing if it and
again that's the other piece too
some of these are tools that help people
sherpa right to make
up for people that are not obviously
this skilled
people it allows people to you know
somebody because that's one thing they
got away from in destiny 2 almost every
raid you all have to be doing something
there's no sword there's the relic is
kind of a clutch moment
but it's not there anymore so this is a
little bit of that now everybody has to
be on your game and doing everything
it's not bad to have equality but
not all players are going to be equal
and to be able to continue to expose
raids to more people
some people are going to have to do more
than others and if this is one thing
that somebody's learned be like hey i
can carry your damage you got to stay
alive you got to handle the oracles
put what damage and you can it's yeah
again i'm with you guys long discussion
aside but it's
it's one of those things the skill skill
ceiling that's really high especially in
a pve activity
in my opinion doesn't really hurt
anybody if you're pulling a pulling an
internet cord
yeah that needs fixed but if it's just
the using what's programmed in the game
i mean there's points where
when you dig into the game like there
was a point where
you could put anarchy on an enemy
switch over to mountaintop as another
grenade launcher
and that was changing the damage that
anarchy would tick so there's some
things just so buried in the code that
they're just going to have to live with
it so right i hope this is one of those
things they don't go like
hard after because yeah either they're
going to take sled shotguns out of one
spot so it's not a thing
or it's one of those things that uh
pulling the cord coming out yeah yeah
yeah so it's like i don't mind a skill
ceiling because again
there's people that are far i'll teach
somebody how to do something at a level
but i'm also not i'll never be esoteric
or glad or any of those guys because
their skills are just insane
so yeah you got to have levels and it's
nice to give those people
something to shoot for no i agree last
point set fred i think said it best
it you know what watch the pros to
inspire us bad players to try something
insane and i
i think it's one of those things that
there are times as
for me like medium skill player right
that
i'll do an encounter i'm like there is
no way this is just way too crazy
right and then you watch these videos
and
you're like yo it could be done okay i
gotta do this i gotta have this set up
and it also gives value so i think
that's important
that inspiration to let the mid and the
casual players say hey
we can actually do this there is a strat
right and let's try this strat that we
see
from you know whoever and and i think
that's a part of destiny
and then don't you want more people
playing the content don't you want
bungie like if you're bungie don't you
want more people having
vlog clears or whatever you know what
i'm saying like i would think you want
them jumping in
every week as opposed to the opposite
well they get frustrated like yo
i'm never doing this i'm good it's not
for me there's no way
like similar to trials right was like oh
i'm getting smashed
i'm not even gonna attempt this i'm out
you know kind of thing i think
it still promotes engagement which i
thought was the end game
and again i feel reload ain't breaking
nothing that's just me but
that's what i had to say yeah it seems
trivial
you know almost trivial yeah it's just
very minute for it to be
to bring the handle so hard but that's
just me what else we got here
uh it's like we knew the 12 was going to
be light so
that's kind of a thing um yeah i didn't
want to go too deep on the stasis
changes and stuff because there are
people who are
for one played with it some there's
going to be videos talking about each of
them kind of describing what's going on
asked across this video was 45 minutes
his videos are not that long so if you
want the details on some of these things
like it's gonna be nasty
yeah it's gonna be nasty yeah so shout
out
um there are definite changes to pvp
with stasis
jump in there see how it feels trials
may not be
quite as crazy um cheating will be a
thing i mean you said
just if you saw out there they're hiring
somebody to work on anti-cheat
um that that's one of two things it's
good thing they're hiring somebody but
it's unfortunate they're
hiring somebody which means it's still
in the process of being worked on so
it's not going to happen around the
corner um
but overall i think there's a light
for what happened in the last kind of
day and a half between the stasis nerf
and the firing range and
you got fire team chat 300
um there's a lot of stuff going on so if
you like believe me go out there if you
don't listen to a whole lot of destiny
podcasts there's going to be a couple
that you're going to want to check out
for sure to learn a little bit more
kind of of an era for fire team chat and
as for this week and in the game itself
yeah
we didn't get a ton we got a new expunge
we got sticks
we got something we got something we're
going to talk i got i got to talk about
it
oh we we did get something oh we got you
in the lore
yeah yeah yeah so we got we got some
story beats
um so i guess i don't want to discount
that the game sticks is a new one which
is cool
um but before to even get to that we got
to see
a cool bit of story from like another
animated storyboard
something that he bought this has been
preaching for a long time yeah
so uh if you want to jump in you're more
than welcome
i've been waiting what i'm waiting for
yeah
uh lauren's story this week so
what do you got what'd you experience
the cut scene
the feeling rumors
cognito take it away sir this one is
this one's yours a lot
going on and again i know you know some
of my destiny folk
you know like oh season you know it's
light i don't really like the content
and i get it that's fair if you don't
you're getting tired of doing override
all the time i feel you
but this week was straight fire
and let me tell you why tuning in the
bungee this week because man
yeah they actually um you know addressed
a lot of stuff we know
um the tension is building this season
obviously the elixi they're here house
light you know myth racks the whole crew
you know falling and trying to you know
help us with this whole situation
with with the vex in this endless night
so after you do the mission
you know what i mean you know you'll
report you're told to report
to i cora and i cora has some choice
things
to say about miss lakshmi yeah he's been
bad-mouthing her
for a while now now if you remember last
week
i gotta throw a little reference don't
get bad eat lakshmi's or her make the
tower great again stuff
oh god so so she's not about these
fallen she is not about these fallen
she's out of control she's loose right
now the only thing i'm gonna give
lashley
is kind of funny she do got one good
point and she's saying look
we're supposed to be a democracy but the
reality is
you know people in the city did you did
did they ask you that the fallen could
come in here
so it's this fun tension brewing and
she's sparking it with these pa
announcements and
she's got you know she's making the town
great again with her foolishness right
so anyway what has now happened is
something you know they have sabotaged
you're the chance funny they are
sabotaged you know
the way the the elixi are staying which
is not that far from nor does it
disclose
the patch rate the either tanks burn you
know they the babies are in danger you
know the fallen babies
it it's not looking good now apparently
crow came at the end to break it up
so what ends up happening is then you
have to go to that part you get to that
part
and um it's it's a tense scene it's it's
myth racks
you know saints they're almost in a cop
role you know to see what's going on
with the situation
and um what and lakshmi's there and
she's not she's not sympathetic she's
not
you know she's like hey you know all
races have been fighting for years
you're not really kind of welcome here
you know we almost would pay the bill
for you to get out like she's really
off the ledge with it but where it
really gets deep
is the cutscene and the cut scene
is probably one of the better ones
they've done
and while they're on the subject of you
monsters being the call in the fallen
old mythrax got a story to tell and he
he man it did not
make saint look good and it basically
showed you know from their perspective
what he represented you know
whether it was you know provoked or
unprovoked
pillaging killing fallen
and the great saint didn't look like a
saying
it looked very very very rough oh man
that was the way they painted him the
perspective is huge when you see it from
there
dude that is like as i don't even i
can't quite picture
it's all to them it almost darth vader
might be a little far of a reach for a
reference but i mean
menacing just absolute terror to their
entire
race like pretty terrifying very
terrifying
kill him he comes back and it basically
is you know one person's hero is another
you know another person's monster and it
was really well done and
it was so well done they say they have
nothing to say and saint liked to talk
satan was quiet so it was one of those
things where it's like
someone pulls up your rap sheet live and
say yeah this is you
this is this is this this all this
murdering pillage
that that's you so it's interesting it
is
it is definitely one of the better beats
in storytelling i fell from destiny
and there's there's a lot of unrest and
the last point and i'll give it to silva
because i want her thoughts on all of
this
was that something even more scary
happened after that
which is you go you know to like they
say they say your cat you stupid
guy say caught say in 4k yeah they
caught him before he got they got the
rap sheet he got him they got him
so but here's the crazy part y'all like
you go to laxby she's doing her thing on
the pa address
and she's like yeah even even the people
of the city
you know they're singing the song and
you hear that
that tune again you know something
something rise from the sun something is
one
and once you heard the tune we already
know what that
is then
[Music]
so savage influences the
moon that's a terrible song bro
savathun's influence
is in the it is spooky y'all it is
spooky
i gotta bring it to i gotta break this
up like what are you thinking silver
like
can we get out this is looking like bad
oh my god
i'ma don't feel bad i'm gonna be real
with you i'm actually
i'm actually behind because what you
started describing
is what i got to today i'm like let me
know why they want to interrupt well
actually
it's a good i love spoilers so now that
i know i have i think i feel like
you're one of the rare ones then but
yeah yes i love
spoilers it helps me keep things
straight helps me keep the facts
straight now that i know like oh my god
it's about to get good you mean
i actually look forward to something
that's developing in the story which i
normally don't
so you just you just you just set the
stage for holy crap what am i about to
about to experience because i'm a week
behind basically
okay okay don't feel bad it sounds
amazing it sounds amazing because i love
saint i love things so i just
i want to i want to like look at this
man and be like
excuse me
[Laughter]
4k i have no clue what you're talking
about
but it sounds like okay the fact that
the season is getting intense this
quickly
that's huge yeah so maybe i should shift
my focus a little bit more
to the seasonal content i've been
getting gm ready and believe me i'm
almost ready so i'm always like
grinding pinnacles i hate that i i hate
doing pinnacles but i have to do it
so that's what i focus on i feel like i
run out of time
to do stuff like you know whatever the
seasonal activity is i love override
um i actually love soloing it believe it
or not
absolutely it's funny it's a funny story
the
the week that the season started uh you
know the first day we all couldn't log
in
and then the next day i was finally able
to get in without deleting my friends
list
turns out i had a nat type issue that i
could not resolve for like two days so i
had to kind of
figure it all out and just solo play so
i got into override by myself and
talk about spoiling the experience um
i like doing it by myself i don't like
doing it with five other blueberries
absolutely no that's impressive funny
it's funny yeah
but you can't technically like like fail
the event you know you can't technically
fail it yeah you can but i love it i
just love it like i can take care of
everything but with five other people
i'm just like
yeah i could see how you could like that
as a song i'm just not yeah so i'm just
not drawn to it but i i do try to at
least
you know get my pinnacles done and maybe
do a little bit more you know because
you know seasonal weekly challenges and
whatnot
but the story is not something i tend to
focus on
gotcha so you know i i was like oh my
god you know
fallen babies like i was i wasn't crazy
but i was like okay this season's gonna
be interesting
right it's gonna be interesting we got
the destiny baby yoda this is gonna be
good
so yeah no i am now i'm excited to get
to that because that sounds incredible
like i won't look up the scene and be
like oh my god i almost want to see this
before i actually see the game but like
now i'm like okay like
you know maybe i'll get out destiny
after this and go you know
it sounds good it sounds very good what
you just described i'm like oh my god
but i did hear that uh what's your name
future word called lady is kind of crazy
like
she crazy well i mean there's a point
where um mythrax
asks like should they have that
technology of like looking into the
future
because also like she's going off a
reference where she sees mithrax in a
burning tower or something along those
lines i think
um but there's no reference of he's near
the tower now
just because he's there doesn't mean he
did it and it's like an incomplete
picture so again it's the reference of
you know having all the facts before you
just decide to say hey the fallen or bad
now granted
you know saints experience has been
trying to survive fallen and everything
else for years and years and years so
obviously he's been trying to
from his perspective protect the
guardians and kill the fallen yeah
on the other side this is he got the not
to cut you he got the history from
twilight gap
which is serious history yeah
no it's like and so there's history on
both sides and that's why i like
the perspective this season has been
interesting last season was like
introducing title getting a feel of like
not a
villain but more um
you know just a different side of
a different race basically the way they
function the way they would work the way
she actually wants us to
kneel in her mind that's not a bad thing
but for us we're not going to do that so
that was a cool way to see that story
this time we have the perspectives of
you know
house light wanting to try and do these
things to
you know they have a chance to you know
basically be under the traveler again
and get near it
he's working with like the vex
technology mithrax is
trying to help us out and help guardians
to try
and because you know we made the motion
in that one mission to not kill him
so it's like there's been this little
build so far and then now you get to see
the perspective of
basically portraying saint as like this
demon figure
it's pretty crazy to see it i love that
they took somebody that
was like oh who's one of your favorite
titans oh saint and then you turn around
and from their perspective it's like
jesus who like it's like the is this
dude
yeah it's like the boogeyman almost i
mean it's yes it's so crazy so it's like
it's really cool to see the way they're
playing with the story
there's speculation of some other stuff
going on and it's like if the
epilogue sits at the end of the calendar
and i swear if they don't do something
with cool story this time
i have to i was like the way they're
building this right now
you know we're gonna have a long season
15 we know that's going to be there
cross play is probably going to be the
thing that tides us over to which queen
but
this is too many implications going on
for them to
not deliver something cool with the
epilogue
because if they're the way it's playing
out so far and we're
is it three or four weeks into the
season three four nine not about i think
four
um there's a lot going on so i i'm
hoping
like this trend of storytelling has been
fantastic i just want to see where it
keeps going because
rumors speculation you know tassie did a
weird video about osiris new red sand
new rad saying it's like stuff taken
kind of out of context so again you can
take it all with a grain of salt
um but it's just the idea of savathun's
song and what she's doing they talked
about setting up the dominoes long time
ago in the vidocq and all that
and again the storytelling at this point
in destiny is some of the best it's ever
been
narrative team is allowed to have a lot
of fun the storyboard cutscenes i'm
absolutely loving each one of those and
this one might have been the best
because it's just like holy hell
um really really cool moments this week
so
definitely digging the stories so far
and just
yeah i'm hoping i don't know if
lakshmi's gonna make it through this
because at some point
i feel like either i cora somebody went
to smoke
is just about the nova bomber out of
existence or smoke
there's some attitude there's some
attitude and attitude dialogue this week
it's good
yeah yeah oh let me tell you where's
just kind of golden gunner straight away
you know how it is when like women talk
you know and talk nasty about each other
boy that's the vibe i'm getting right
now it's like oh god can we just watch
them fight it out please i would love to
see that scene
oh now because like like i said it it's
so funny though i've never
acora had sass on it too she was like oh
no we we're gonna have a talk be a lunch
we're gonna have to have a talk i was
like
oh chill over here girl you go ahead and
do that
but um yeah there's other was one other
thing too um there's two aspects i would
have mentioned without going too crazy i
don't understand spoiler thing so
but um no no no no you're good you're
good the
another thing that's pretty honorable i
thought was
mythrax because he's really trying to
hold it together
yeah and it you know they it's
not to get political but it it's a great
storyline because
it's like you know immigrants or
refugees coming over
right and there's this whole dynamic
well they're not us
they're not from us this is our borders
we you know and then obviously these
groups have been in conflict right so
it's such a
well-done story this is like really
prime bungee narrative and i gotta
salute the team like
you know we complain about the game but
the last three seasons i would say the
narrative team been on
fire like they've been in their bag and
i i just think that
you know with this you got the mythrax
thing and then
his daughter was pissed yeah the pissed
you don't kind of thing
and the last thing i say is you know
when i spawn too much but
i got it i got it i gotta admit
i know you know you know who my man's is
you know who my mans i am
team osiris-100 oh my god
it's looking sus right now
something is up with my man
and if you did this override mission
you'll hear at the end
mythrax is like yo we i don't again i'm
not gonna spoil too much
we gonna do that oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
and he almost stutters and i'm just like
yo what is going on with him
and i got some theories you know we can
we could do that another time or
whatever but
something is up with my man
and and i i hope it's not the worst case
scenario
because
i i am such a fanboy and i don't want to
say this but
it's either a
he is not
osiris
[Laughter]
my man is gone
because this is out of character
and and the last part is you know how we
got confirmation to some extent
in the lord i forgot shout out to if
he's got a great video out
in the lore laxmi is like remember she's
starting her cool she's trying to
turn over the vanguard take this thing
over right
she first says she tries to approach
saladin
and saladin is she thought because he
was so
if you did battlegrounds saladin was
very antagonistic i don't like what
follows doing and we need to go kill the
cabal
he was very you know antagonistic so she
was his first
her first choice to join in the coup but
then
she said no it's not working because he
still has loyalty
to zavala dana she makes a comment about
my man
in the past she was like he's one of the
most unpredictable
persons right guardians all of a sudden
she says
osiris is very pro on
is strangely predictable lately right
that was the first tell right to me
tell number two we know the relationship
the bungie writers have come out and
said osiris and say are a thing that's a
fact
that's that's the boo thing right so
when he came back from season of the
hunt
right there was a law piece with aikora
almost consoling saint
like yo boo don't talk to me no boy like
what's going on with him like
he don't you know what i'm saying like
he just as soon as he came back
he's he's off to the helm he's not so
everybody was like oh he's mourning
segera
that was the talk right but to say he's
like yo he's not acting like his normal
self
that was that was tell two tell three
crow we all know since crow has been
back
he's been in a mental role to osiris
right
he won saved the first assassination
attempt
on zavala in the tower if you remember
my man was like why was he doing that he
was getting mad at him he was like you
know why would you
and what you call it was like yo i i did
the research there was an attempt on his
life why are you getting mad i did the
right thing
no don't ever be at the tower again
chastising him
all the time for trying to do the right
thing and doing all this stuff
so the thing i have is this and i'm
gonna hit you with this bombshell y'all
not too much but i think a lot of people
don't where i'm going is
why is it that crow when you won't pass
him
the helm he's singing savithon's
greatest hit
yep oh my god
so in order for you to to have according
to eris
in order for you to have that song
uttering you either have to be a
in close proximity to some relic like
she said shax is
right mm-hmm only only thing crow been
doing is chilling in the hell ain't no
ain't no old relics that saboteur could
use to influence
unless somebody is savator
and that's where i'm going with it he
ain't right
man i don't think we and then we never
seen segura
die on screen remember i was mad at that
as a fanboy i was like yo how you going
to take his ghost away and we don't see
it and then all of a sudden oh yeah i
lost her
oh i know i'm going scooby doo i know
yes but my thing is
i'm telling you right now something
right either he is it's complete
imposter or
she's controlling him so something is
not
right my theory is the real osiris
and the real seguera is trapped
somewhere else
and this person
masquerading as my man bro
come on like why is crow singing the
song
this is all going so over my head it's
so funny that's crazy that's my theory
crazy
right if i'm right remember cox said it
first i opp
the last word 150 what is it 152 clip
this
if i'm right y'all this is my greatest
joy ever that
if i'll be able to figure this one out
but i think i think sabbath is amongst
us in the flesh
that's not that's not all bro that's not
my i know my man
that he ain't acting right he didn't
mean the president
he's not eva levante not even
the president he he brought he brought
even cato was like what are you doing
why would you bring that what is it the
crown
sorrow why are you bringing that back to
the crib you know
what the the powers and the influence
that thing he doing all type of while he
let lakshmi run wild
and she says i have a person of
influence
in my circle that's cooperating watch
out y'all
watch out be careful mike be careful
always oh it's not right
that's my thing i'm running with it top
gear style on that bombshell no only a
few people are gonna get that reference
um but seriously like that's
those type of speculations and then
they've actually presented the story in
front of people enough you've seen it
impressage with a crown
you dug into the lord a little bit more
but you're here in the voiceover lines
all of these things right now are at a
place to where it is a lot of fun to
pay attention to the story of destiny
there have been times where it's been
ups and downs and you'll get little
pieces here and there
but overall i think it's been
really cool if nothing else even said
fred said it before he's like you know
it's like the gameplay you know leveling
you know may have its you know ups and
downs and stuff but it's like it's like
i'm digging the story more than ever and
it's like and i think that's where
people who want to jump into the pve
stuff and keep up with the season
these seasons like the writing they're
putting in the voice lines
remember picture what you're getting for
ten dollars and tell me this stuff is
not worth it oh yeah
the amount of stuff that they're
developing like the override they made
the
the camp the voiceover lines that now
cycled through and they have different
voiceover lines from idaho the daughter
after they destroy it like they are
doing
amazing stuff with these like the story
the seasons and things like that
and if it is just like the tuesday story
is worth tuning in every week because i
want to see the next episode
i can't like now like now instead of
just being like a page in a book before
now now i'm almost getting an episode
every week like this is this is a little
more living up to
worthwhile and checking in so that's
it it's a lot of fun i'm really enjoying
the story and i can't wait to see where
it goes because
queen which queen starts the end of this
saga
we're building into that right now and
they're doing a lot of cool stuff so i
i as as you said is osiris
not good doing sus things like who knows
but overall
they get a whole lot of cards that they
can play with and i'm curious which
one's gonna fall like where it's all
gonna go so
and even if i'm wrong the the the thing
about it that scary
is regardless to to that theory
savathun is in position and and
regard even regardless what happens we
are in
serious trouble like this is worse than
to me this is worse than oryx this is
like that they're setting up witch
queens so beautifully to me
that and then with the name being
lightfall what what's gonna happen y'all
we we in trouble we might be going to
that uh what is it that uh infinity
infinity war moment we gotta say oh my
god that would be amazing
they're gonna be crying people gonna be
crying in the towel i'm telling you
let's go we go it's getting deep y'all
pay attention it's gonna be lit
i think so that dude is gonna be the
take of the the taken king of destiny 2.
it yeah it's setting up where it has
potential to be
to be that epic and i just hope they can
deliver
it may not be all in the first expansion
and built over like the future stuff but
like
which queen has potential to send this
whole seven years of
a lot of building a lot of kinks working
out a whole lot of figuring out how this
is gonna work but if this is the story
model and how things are gonna go these
last three years look to be some of the
best that we're gonna have
but next tuesday yeah seriously
but that's about all i got that i think
we got this week i mean we didn't deep
dive on the stasis nerfs
go play it see how it feels i don't need
to go through numbers and stuff there's
people better about that
um iron banner will be next week go
enjoy vaulted glass find some friends
it's cool to jump in there
uh but overall tune in tuesdays enjoy
what the story is doing right now and
catch up on it if you missed it it's
definitely a good time to be involved
um but for this episode um as we wrap it
up
silver this kind of becomes your time to
let people know
where to find you what you got going on
what you can help them with in sherpas
where they can look for you
everything you got going on in your
world the best places to find you
um the floor is yours so talk to the
people
all right well it's basically easy uh
you can find me at silverspeare on
basically
any and every platform
twitch twitch twitter twitch uh youtube
tick tock uh
instagram i'm on i'm everywhere i'm very
active on twitter
um basically i'm just prepping for gms
doing my pinnacles doing vault of glass
getting ready for master
um like you know like the uh the athlete
training for the season
that's what i'm doing you're in training
camp right now you know you're you're
up in your stats you know you're going
through the level you're going through
the
the training camp yep yep yep
because once the gm start i'm basically
going to be living in them and
you know i won't you won't pull me out
of there for anything else like
i might have to for the seasonal content
because y'all getting me really hyped up
like
okay it's like you need to start paying
attention to this
i mean honestly i would say like it
doesn't take that long and if you've
already been playing override some
it doesn't take that much time to
experience it no so i would definitely
spend the time to catch up on it it's
totally worth it
yeah yeah it it doesn't so yeah
basically i'm always around i'm on
twitter interacting with people
all the time even when i should probably
be sleeping
but overall hit me up i'm uh i'm here i
love
i love meeting new people i love playing
with new people um
definitely looking to sherpa people i do
not have the sherpa emblem so i'm just
you know
even if there wasn't an emblem i just
want to i just want to play and vibe
with people you know i i love that
i really do yeah yeah
just like to have fun argue with that
cognito what do you got coming up
anything exciting in the ilp
world yeah yeah a lot of stuff before i
get into that salute
lady silver spirit did her thing she was
worried about
anything not to talk about i told you
people have to talk about told you
[Laughter]
we got to get into it and then i'm good
but like anxiety just
hypes me up to the point where i'm like
you're good you're good
you're fantastic great i love what
you're doing yeah i love what you're
doing in the community
great conversation i love how you
include people you
you know bring people together and it's
dope it's dope and we got to set up do
my best
i do my best just keep it real that's
all i can do i don't have enough energy
to do anything but keep it real
like i i i really don't like i feel like
i'm like
20 years older than i really am
so i'm like i gotta keep it completely
you're fine
i'm at the point where it's like listen
if you don't get it then
i can't i don't know what to tell you
man i got nothing
it's all right i laid it all out and you
do whatever you want
i'm kidding i don't i'm not faking
anything if i'm having a bad time people
are gonna know about it not because i
wanna you know spread negativity but
it's like listen i'm human
i like to be positive spread positivity
but i also have my flaws like you know
you know times get tough because
it's constantly keeping a balance
absolutely
people know that they can expect me to
show all sides which is
doing well doing not so well um
trying to self-motivate myself to keep
going
you know and and it's just a constant
thing and so people get to see it all
no that's dope because that that's yeah
that's life that's reality
so that nobody can say like oh you know
silver spears fake
okay you know why you clearly aren't
paying attention that's what that tells
me
exactly i'm not i don't have to worry
about that you know i'm at peace with
what i put out there which is
exactly as it is yep i got nothing to
hide
reaching good yeah so definitely go make
sure you're camera shy
i'm a little camera shy but i'm not
really hiding anything hey that's
no big deal camera is not required to do
what you do so
all good i appreciate it i appreciate it
cognito sir
yeah yeah for me man you already know
that like did on twitter um check this
out but this
past couple of weeks we've been doing
the what we call the e3 prediction
series it's kind of big for us
we do all the major companies
unfortunately because we didn't know
nintendo's date until very late
it won't be a big nintendo one but we
did uh sony last week
uh and now we're doing the microsoft
show it's gonna be a big show
check us out sunday 1 p.m eastern we'll
have
d uh dealer gaming we'll have acg
tim dawg kid small mister it's going to
be a huge who's you who's who
so to speak of the xbox community so
come check that out we'll do our
predictions you know as we get
wrap up to e3 to you i think it's going
to be shorter than last week
no if you guys
like have to commute across the state
you might download
last week's episode because how long was
it
about four and a half hours once you got
rid of the intro four and a half hours
and i was like
yeah i i have not covered it all but
yeah there's definitely some
entertaining moments sometimes stamp
show there's time stamps let's see this
is good
there you go we always put the time
stamps in so if you want to go straight
to your topic or what you want to do
yeah these shows sometimes get out of
control but playstation was a lot of fun
we loved speculating with that
and very passionate so again this week
xbox check us out sunday 1 p.m eastern
on the iron lords podcast youtube
channel every sunday is the lord's day
check us out
also if you um are a fan of um
defining duke those guys acg and maddie
plays
i was i was humbly invited to uh to be
on defining duke this week i had a great
time
they just i think they put it up now the
episode now it's on their patreon i
think sunday goes live to the rest of
the world
on youtube as well so check that out and
um yeah
um also lords of gaming.net i have to
stress it um
shout out to the team we've been doing
this thing called the lord's minute we
actually have this discussion
uh destiny and about what's going on
with destiny lord so again if you go to
lords of gaming.net
check that out we've got some great um
articles opinion pieces
and of course check us out
here that last word podcast
my man e always a pleasure man racing
home from the gym to do this podcast for
y'all
just letting y'all know he came through
with the with the messy head and he
that's the passion passion
indeed that's the passion not always
looking the best up there but i'm here
oh my god don't even give yourself more
credit
you're looking you got it you got it got
you got it you got it you're doing your
thing but now i wanted to salute you
because i know
you've been working hard there's a lot
of secret things he's working on you all
that
yes but y'all see i i'm privy to the
information
you'll see you'll see it sometime today
so if nothing else i'll tell you guys
what it was next week so
yeah he's working really hard and yeah
i'm proud of him he's proud of me
you've got his advanced gg sponsorship
no idea what it is but i'm proud to
because i know what bond says he's the
homie he's the homie he's
known him for i've known him for a while
not that poor so worth it or as i call
him sometimes
said no bee
since i heard that one hey you remember
day one when you and i met i was like yo
sit dopey i don't get that one much
you'll get that one that's not me
absolutely
it uh always a pleasure doing that last
work what you got going on
uh as i said like you guys will figure
out what i worked on
yesterday you'll see it sometime today
you may not know it's me but i'll tell
you what it is next week
uh but other than that started mass
effect so i got a couple hours in but
the week got crazy so
a couple hours in lots of world
buildings so far very cool so
if i get some down time to play after
workouts and stuff i want to get a
decent chunk of stream on that one
uh but we're not far away from like
ratchet and clank and a couple other
things that are coming up so
lots of stuff is coming in june which is
looking busy
for gaming for one and then news of
games for e3 and everything else is
going on too so
gonna be a very busy week i'll cover
what i can stream live stuff if i'm
actually able to watch the conferences
some will be around some i won't but
lots of news and just excited for of
course
more destiny and more gaming so i'm i'm
too old but it's still way too much fun
doing this so i'll keep it up so you
guys can always find me twitch twitter
youtube ebontis
it's pretty much where i'm at so uh for
this episode thank you guys very much
chat has been
a hell of a lot of fun a lot of a lot of
good times in there
uh silver thank you very much it's been
a pleasure having you on glad we made
this thing work and
sorry for the slight delay but you know
i got i got here so um
it was a pleasure and an honor of course
make sure you guys go follow both of
these amazing people
follow silver you know check her out on
twitch he's doing awesome things
always just lots of fun and love in that
room and
over on iron lord's podcast check out
the podcast if you got four and a half
hours still
that's one of them and then xbox
probably is not going to be much shorter
so these are
uh these are good um so they're always a
great way to
uh if you got a lot of stuff to work on
you got to build a giant piece of ikea
furniture whatever you got to do that's
going to take a while this is your time
and it's a good way to get a lot of cool
people's perspectives and they have fun
get a little emotional but it's good
time so
for this episode it's been a blast
number 152
june 4. thank you guys for hanging this
morning and
for this episode it has been
the last word